eleven Republicans in the House of
Representatives have sent a letter to
the Justice Department calling for the
criminal investigations of wait for it
James Comey Hillary Clinton Andrew
McCabe and Loretta Lynch Fox's chief
national correspondent Edie Henry is
more on that Edie
Marco to see the behind the scenes story
I'm getting his attorney general Jeff
Sessions this still does not appear to
be moving quick enough on alleged abuses
by the FBI Justice Department for the
liking of top advisors to President
Trump's they've been prodding
Republicans on Capitol Hill to jump in
so congressman Ron De Santis in ten
other House Republicans have now taken
the initiative to send this criminal
referral to the FBI director Chris Ray
two sessions and to US Attorney John
Huber remember he was tasked by the
Attorney General to evaluate whether
there needs to be criminal charges for
actions like abuse of FISA by Obama
officials to spy in the Trump campaign
at the top of their list for potential
charges as you mentioned Hillary Clinton
for using fuse and GPS to disguise
payments from her presidential campaign
for that anti Trump dossier a link not
disclosed when top officials got that
FISA warrant to spy on former Trump
adviser Carter Paige a Clinton aide
tells Fox there's no merit to this claim
and Republicans must be acting up here
because they're scared about the
upcoming midterms that's their view the
criminal referral also targets FBI
officials like Peter struck and Lisa
Paige remember their anti Trump text
messages seem to reveal a bias and help
contribute to the agency's bungling of
that probe into Clinton's server former
FBI chief James Comey also targeted for
signing three FISA applications without
disclosing the funding from the Clinton
camp and the DNC for that dossier as
well as the fact he drafted an
exoneration statement months before
Clinton's FBI interview that appears to
contradict sworn testimony to Congress
where Comey said he only made the
decision to not charge her after she was
questioned by the FBI Comey and his
former number two at the FBI Andrew
McCabe also cited for leaks to the media
including charges that classified info
got out from the release of those memos
that Comey put together today he
insisted he did nothing wrong and is
confident he will be exonerated but
here's where it gets really interesting
after Comey told the view he believes
McCabe is a good person but the Justice
Department Inspector General fide found
that
lied about his leaking McCabe fired back
it's not true and that Comey is simply
not being honest so you've got the
former g-men now turning on each other
McCabe and Co me you're gonna be again a
lot more interesting soon mark yeah
thank thanks for that Ed I'll believe it
when I see it it may be quicker for
Donald Trump to launch a new reality
show Celebrity chain gang I would love
to see those guys on it